let's talk about open assistant
sure so start from the beginning
um well
we saw that there was a lot of movement
in in this space uh chat GPT came along
and everyone's like chat jpt and so on
and
um
yeah I think it was a I mean it was both
a surprise and a not surprise for for
people like the capabilities of chat GPT
weren't as surprised but obviously the
success of it I think to many of us was
it's like ah okay
we knew we could build such you know
chat conversational like things but we
didn't know how much people loved them
right
um there's a bit of a I think it wasn't
didn't didn't Sam Altman maybe was that
who said in an interview well anyone
could have built this using our API
before right but no one did so you know
we we did which is not true because they
distinctively forbade like you building
an app that
um had unfiltered access to the API
essentially I open-ended apps I think
they've explicitly forbade that right so
that it's a wrong statement that anyone
could have built this using our API
because had they tried you would have
shot them down right yes but in essence
the capabilities were there and um it's
still in the Restriction now unless
they've changed it they do not allow
open-ended applications which seems like
an oxymoron to me because a language
model is inherently open-ended yeah but
I can I mean I can see their the
Restriction being like you know you're
not allowed to build an app that just
lets users free form query our app you
need to either do some filtering or do
some heavy prompting around it so that
it's like for one particular purpose I
can see that I can totally get why they
do it but then at the same time saying
anyone could have built chat gpts like
no chat GPT is very like if I could
imagine an app that has like unfiltered
unfeathered access to the API through an
app it's chat GPT right
um
in any case there was obviously a lot of
of and then
I think pretty soon people came up with
this idea hey could we do something like
that open source they had a bit of an
older paper called instruct GPT or that
described a model called instruct GPT
that where they sort of outlined how we
think chat GPT was done approximately no
one knows but
um and at that point we also saw hey the
amount of data to be collected is
actually in reach right it's not it's
not
immense humongous and so on it's
actually okay and and and could be done
so at that point yeah a lot of people
wanted to do something open source like
and um I think a bunch of us just came
together and and felt
we could do it so we built this platform
where people could come and contribute
uh to the data set which was really cool
to see that people actually came and
um amazing
open source well well the the point is
the point is there were a lot of ideas
around as well of oh let's just collect
you know scrape Quorum scrape Reddit
right and that will serve like as
training date and it's true to an amount
right but it's very clear at least to me
that the capabilities of these models
the the chat models they come from the
underlying language model right the the
and the the biggest claim to that I have
is that open AI said they used crowd
workers from low wage countries uh to
you to do their data input yet EV the
first examples of chat GPT that flew
around were like oh look at it's solving
this quantum physics problem and so on
now I'm I'm not saying that there aren't
any good Quantum physicists in in other
countries right but the the people who
typically go for like a low-wage crowd
worker job in these countries they
probably aren't uh experts in quantum
physics and they also certainly weren't
paid to go get a degree in it just so
they could answer that one question so
to me it's very clear that the
capabilities come from the underlying
model from the the next token prediction
pre-training and then
all the human data does is kind of it
gets it into this mood of being an
assistant right gives it lots of
examples of who here is how it's like
you know going through to an
apprenticeship or something like this
where you've lived your life right
you've grown up you've consumed the
world and so on and then you you start
your first job and someone tells you
look here is how you behave towards
customers right you're you're friendly
you know if someone asks this you do it
like this here is a thing here is how
our system works and so you get
introduced to that but your competence
of just living and doing things comes
from yourself for your life and not from
that one person who introduces you to
how the store works and how you should
behave towards customers so
my big conviction was always we should
really collect this data from humans and
the goal should really be diversity so
the goal and and if you just say well
we'll just scrape you know 10 000
um of this then to me that certainly is
going to do something right it's good
data probably but it's a bit missing the
point if you want a general assistant
you need as general data as you can get
and only human data so far has been able
to
achieve that level of diversity and
generality and it was proven like okay
I'm biased but I think it was proven
right a little bit in that if you look
at the data set
um the prompts that human right like
what they want to know what they want
the model to do yeah it's so diverse
it's insane and so we built this
platform or essentially you as a human
you can come and you're always presented
with like one task and the task could be
write the prompt right but the task
could also be here is an already
existing conversation between a human
and an assistant and now it's the
assistant's turn and now you play the
assistant please write your response
right it could also be here is a
conversation
here is the last message of the
conversation it's the reply by the
assistant please rate it like label it
is it is it spam is it a troll right
um is it is it funny is it appropriate
does it fulfill what the human wanted
out of it right and so that's how we
constructed the data set and we
collected over like six hundred thousand
inputs of such that being text or or
labels or rankings of different things
and yeah that's that resulted in in this
data set over 13 000 people contributed
to the data set which is uh mind-blowing
mind-blowing to see it's really cool and
we've just made the data set fully
available
um you can you can go and and look at it
and download it there are a lot of so we
have about 10 000 what we call
um fully annotated conversation trees
which is like a root note The Prompt and
different answers from it and then from
those potential sometimes different
answers and so on we have sampled we've
set our parameters in various ways so
sometimes it's short trees sometimes
it's big trees
and sometimes it's white trees right and
so you can you can go look at all of
that we have over 10 000 of those trees
which is is really cool because you can
see the same conversation like taking a
bit alternate turns and yeah and so on
and we have like tons and tons of
prompts like the we have probably like
50 000 or so or Twenty Thousand at least
like just prompts like people who come
and wanna know we got so much prompts we
had to implement like and Andreas has
has
um
um Andreas who's has been very
influential in this in this project and
uh he's he's he had to implement this
prompt Lottery where really we we first
if people enter a prompt it first goes
into this Lottery thing right and then
we sample from that and I think we
adjust it so that one person can't
like if some one person
puts a lot of prompts it's like sampled
less so that every person has kind of
like the same or a similar chance of
getting there prompt into the the system
right because one prompt then generates
you know probably a hundred tasks
because it's all the responses and the
responses to the responses and the
rankings and the labels and it's been
fun it's been uh absolute fun and a
pleasure to work with the people also
the people who've contributed code it's
amazing people just they come and they
they ask for nothing right they're just
like oh this is cool I want to be part
of this and uh and they see that
everyone else excited too and then they
they contribute code some contribute
like lots and lots of of code which is
amazing some just come and they they
contribute you know there's a here's an
issue I'll do it and that's that's cool
too so yeah it's been cool well first of
all thank you for doing this it's
absolutely amazing well thank the people
like I've I've just been the noise
machine right
I know that I mean when when you when
you published all of that information on
your YouTube channel that you're working
on it I'm sure everyone jumped on it but
I I do have a few questions the reason
why it's so exciting is just like Connor
did we used to be friends of Connolly he
were chatting with him years ago and he
just um we're still friends
I mean he's because he's a busy guy now
yeah but we were we were chatting all
the time and he just kind of set up a
life at Ai and just got you know I think
yeah Google on board and he just said
you know what I'm gonna build the pile
and I'm just going to build this massive
data set and I'm just going to train
this massive language model and you know
it's just like a random guy and like he
wasn't him alone though there was a
whole team yeah but no but it was an
excitement to create it was visceral it
was so exciting and and they pulled it
off against all the odds and then you've
done exactly the same thing which is
remarkable but I have a few questions
which is that most of these other
language models are not very good so Nat
Friedman's got like a Dev website where
you can play with all of the language
models and most of them aren't very good
even the ones that should be good aren't
very good and um and what people might
find surprising is that you can take a
model and let's say you're using the
Llama model from from meta and it's a
foundation model that has all of the
capabilities and it's been trained
because you said diversity is important
it's got diversity it's been trained on
on everything but it's not very good and
then you do this fine tuning and I think
people need to be clear that what you're
doing is not our lhf it's fine tuning
with you so the model we have on the
website as of time of this recording is
one that's just fine-tuned on the human
data we're doing the rlhf as well
um so all of this is happening like in
parallel it's just already these these
fine-tuned models they're performing
quite well I think and thus we just
wanted to get them out right before we
were like all done and
um yeah but people are now free to take
the data set and do their own
reinforcement learning and whatnot and
we're happy to take back these models if
they they turn out to be good yeah well
I think people might be surprised by
that because you've taken a model which
probably wasn't very good and you
fine-tuned it with this diverse human
creative data now
it was not very good at being like an
assistant so as I said the the
capabilities that we unlock quote
unquote right they they were in there
all along and it's still not very good
even with our fine tuning for certain
tasks
um some of which is clearly the well the
fault the the some of which can clearly
be traced to the underlying model for
example the underlying model if it's for
example the Llama model it's 30 billion
parameters it's not it's not gpt3 size
even like it's 10 times smaller probably
than gpt4 however big that is right so
it's gonna have
it's not going to be the same like it's
it's it's it's it's
you I don't we don't want to claim it's
like as good as they same it's probably
been trained on much less code for
example than the the GPT models of open
Ai and thus we we see that uh coding for
example is a is a weakness of the model
and they're they're although people tell
me with like lower temperature it's
actually pretty good I I've not explored
that yet but it's so the underlying
model I think llama is a pretty good
model right it's not been super good at
being an assistant out of the box but
it's it's quite a good model and as I
said all we do is we can kind of unlock
that and bring it to the surface well
that's kind of what I want to get to
that
um people like Connolly he he Galaxy
brained himself and he knew that GPT 3
was a good model and and I was saying no
it's not Conor what you're talking about
and
it's almost like what you're doing with
this fine tuning you're not really
adding any capability you're just
getting it in the mood the capability is
already there but it gets into the
philosophy of what do we recognize as
intelligence and that's relevant to the
previous conversation we were having so
when the average person plays with llama
they probably won't find it as useful
they might not recognize it as
intelligent you create all of this
training data now I want to touch on the
process of creating the training data
because I think it's really important
what you're doing is you're creating
counterfactual trajectories it's very
similar to Kenneth Stanley's pick
pre-diar algorithm if you remember that
so it's actually an open-ended process
in a way like we stop so as I said we it
starts with The Prompt right we sample
that and then we ask like
three humans to each create a
continuation alternate as yeah like an
alternate path in the conversation and
into those we again Ask two or three
humans to hey because the prompt is from
what we call the prompter role that
would be like the human interaction and
then the assistant is like the
counterparty in our system all of this
is PL is done by humans like we we have
to distinguish the words a bit like user
is really the human and then prompter is
the role in the conversation and then
assistant is the other role right in our
system
in our data collection system this is
all done by humans for data collection
purposes and yeah so we create these
three of conversations where yeah you
have three assistant replies to the
first prompt let's say and to each of
these assistant reply you have three
um prompter replies and the prompter
replies could be something like ah you
got that wrong or could you clarify
something or you know please do it in a
different way or elaborate on something
you said and then to each of those we
again have an assistant reply and we
modify a bit like the width and sampling
of all of that but at some point we cut
it off and we say okay the tree is done
now it has like I don't know 50 or 100
messages inside of it so you know
package that boom next from it's not
open-ended in the way that like
Stanley's open-ended experiments are in
in the sense that we do cut it off after
some steps and then we take the next
prompt because we otherwise we just have
one big conversation which would maybe
be fun too right to just have because
conversation meanders right and we just
have like one one big conversation at
any point you could say like I changed
my mind let's do something else I mean I
think what I was trying to capture that
and Stanley is big on
um people following the gradient of
interestingness and that's kind of what
you've captured so they Meander they
take trajectories and then the model
learns an interesting manifold and we'll
get into simulators maybe you were just
talking about that we've just done a
show on simulators it's a very
interesting idea that language models
basically have a superposition of agents
and you can kind of get them in the mood
to behave like a certain agent and and
in a sense what you've done is is
through all of these counterfactual
creative interesting trajectories of
conversation you're kind of like fitting
it to some structure which fits really
nicely to humans
I guess I mean it it obviously covers in
like three answers to a to a to it to
some text covers in no way the extent of
what humans would do but it just creates
like a little bit of different training
data for one it creates a it creates
because we also rank the different thing
we ask humans say well which one of
these is best it also creates a bit of a
signal for Quality right again with the
labels that we have and a bit of
diversity like okay here is three ways
you could respond to that particular
thing right so yeah I
I think it's a it's a it's been a
worthwhile effort to do this instead of
just collecting like single
conversations
um obviously exponentially multiplies
the effort humans have to put in but I
think it was obviously I don't have I
don't interestingly I don't have the
counter factual in the world where we
just would have collected conversations
uh but I think it's been it's been worth
it and uh it's it's turned out well
amazing well quick digression on the
Waluigi effect
um I know you've got an interesting take
on this so the um we did a video on it
but the quick idea is that
um do you remember being it would
digress to a angst teenage child within
about three messages and uh less wrong
it wasn't actually less wrong I think
it's the alignment Forum but I just kind
of mentally back at them all in the same
place but um they they said that it's
because you get these antithetical
agents so still a simulated Theory and
because of structural narratology in all
the data they're trained on you tend to
have agents that are you know you have
the antithesis of the agent in the same
story
and they say that the embedding space
between the agent and the antithesis is
so close together just like in word to
Vex stop and go we're very close
together and that our lhf kind of you
know clusters them and it doesn't filter
out the waluigi's what do you think
about it yes that's a bunch of rubbish
I'm in Britain now I should I should
start talking that's a lot of bollocks
mate talking like you
um no I think that's I I said this to
you before um I think that's when you
when you just when you have someone who
is
um you know educated and and good with
words but you just tell them like just
ramble a bit like that's what you get
out you get out posts or or up like I'm
not saying this this doesn't obviously
have a claim to it and and and could be
tested and all of this kind of stuff and
I don't have evidence for the fact that
it's not true I just don't think it is
right maybe that's a that's a rambling
claim too or a bit of um but I don't I
don't it's a very specific claim and
that specific claim would have to have
good evidence behind it and I think
there isn't much less
uh specific like there's a much more
obvious
reason to why these models degrade uh
and that thing goes like no you've been
a bad user and so on and that's that's
just I I
and you can compare it to yourself or or
to to an assist before like we talked
about apprenticeship you it's the the
this tuning is like a bit of an
apprenticeship you go you're you come
out of school you go into a store you
get employed there right then the
manager tells you you know here is how
we treat customers we we're always
respectful even if they're a little rude
right you're you remain respectful right
at some point if it gets too rude like
you just say I'm sorry I can't can't do
that right and you just you know never
insult the customer never do that
if you go to a store now you can be
quite a bit of a and I'm not saying I've
tried this right but you can probably be
quite a bit of a dick for a while but
eventually you'll get under their skin
like eventually you'll say something
about
their mother or about their appearance
or about their intelligence or something
that gets that gets them right and at
that point you will not have a friendly
customer a support person there you will
have like some person that's going like
easier no you like he's like and then
it's becomes
ugly and and this is this is inside of
of humans
um and it's in my fact an inextricably
inextricably linked to being a competent
being in in the world right because if
you if you don't know what anger is
you're not competent right if you don't
even if you yourself never you know
Express anger let's say in a raging way
you still know what it is and if I asked
you to like act like it you could still
do it and if I insult you in the correct
way you probably would do it and so I
think it's much more much more that it's
it is a way that humans have in them
they can behave like this it's totally
normal if you poke them enough and
that's what the statistical model
represents it's just it's very likely
that if you go and you poke them the
human and equivalently the statistical
distribution of humans right if you Oak
them enough and you insult them enough
they will come back and be like no F off
right you're you're a dumb user no
um and yeah I don't know it's not it's
not too it's very close in embedding
space it's like no this is what happens
when you go to humans and poke them and
insult them and Ergo if you do the same
with these models they will react in the
statistically likely way of treating
human and yes on top of that there are
like adverse area sorry that was
embarrassing they were like adversarial
examples where okay maybe you say the
exact number of words so that the
matrices line up and the singular value
pops off and it goes really much into
this direction right and then you get
the weird answer right like like a
mathematical
happening right but in essence in
essence it's it's just yo that's the
data right it's it's not the world Luigi
but um what's really interesting and and
I buy into everything you've just said
is that all of that chaos you know the
shogoth meme all of the beast that's
actually necessary because we have this
puritanical view of language models
people like Gary Marcus they would say
all of that crap should be cut out all
of the racism all of the bias and even
if they have been trained on the Corpus
of the internet they may well pick up on
a very human behavior which is that our
affect changes dramatically over time
yeah but do you want that like um
obviously all of us would be would be
totally in favor if you come and you say
look I have a competent assistant
that doesn't you know I guarantee you
there is not an ounce of you know swear
word in that thing right do you the way
to
like do you want an assistant like let's
think about human assistance like you
you're fortunate enough to be able to
hire like a personal assistant right
some people
have that luxury right and do you want
one that says oh no whenever there's a
scene in a movie where people like get a
bit roughed or get a bit angry at each
other I just go like this right I just
plug my ears and I go like I've in fact
I don't know what happens after and I
don't wanna know right it's it's this is
not in my knowledge this is not in my
training distribution whatever happens
if humans get a bit angry at each other
and Beyond I don't know right if do you
want some person like this or do you
want a person who's just Grown Up
Normally and just has been socialized
well to not do that like to not get
angry even though they could
with the knowledge that yes if you
insult them enough they will get angry
right which one do you want to me
I want the competent one I want the one
who knows what anger is I want the one
who knows that
something like I don't know something
like racism exists and who is aware that
it's like a thing that to be to be
combated to be you know aware of people
like this exist here is how they think
right here is maybe why they think what
they think where they're wrong right in
order to be competent to be able to
battle it in order to be confident to be
able to avoid it and
so I think these things are a
necessary component of competence and
not that I would want them in there but
I think you you cannot be competent in
the world
not having knowledge and ability to do
these things yeah exactly and a lot of
this is about these sounds that are not
made or aren't are not observable so
when you work any job there's your
public behavior and then there's what
you're really thinking and what you say
in private behind the scenes and your
ability to be competent and understand
what's going on in the ecosystem of that
business is driven by the sugar there's
all of this stuff going on inside you
that two sides of the same coin and also
it's about what makes you human and
maybe it's a reason why there will be no
super intelligence because these things
are scarily good at being human but they
in many ways have the flaws of Being
Human eventually they'll just want to
chill on on the beach and and like
smoke a joint and relax and be like nah
all this work no
um they're too human
um yeah but I think so too right and I I
think
you you're if you're not competent like
that if you don't have the inner
monologue that tells you hey that other
human
um I think they're kind of they kind of
want to you know screw me over because
I'm gonna get a promotion soon and
they're trying to you know do think if
you're not able to model that inside of
yourself you you're gonna
I'm not saying everyone else is evil
right there are tremendously nice humans
and all but
I I think we've all been served well by
considering hey other humans might not
be the nicest people and here is how
they might think internally so having
that competence if you don't have that
you're just naive and you you just
you're gonna go down right and you're
not gonna achieve anything productive or
much productive because
you need to be able to be prepared for
someone else being adversarial so
language models do have a theory of mind
well again that's like a word right that
we've ascribed to I mean essentially all
of this word play comes down to well if
I have a concept X right and and I
assign X to a human and if I have a
thing that just
acts in the exactly the same way as some
as a human who has X do I now apply X to
thing
and it's a matter of definition right
certainly the the models can or maybe
better versions more and more will be
able to act as if they had a theory of
mind
do you now apply the word or not who
cares it's a matter of definition
so coming back to open Assistant tell me
about the
um the legals first of all so
um you are presumably
storing the data that people do
inferencing with and you're publishing
it and obviously that's made very very
clear and the whole thing is done in the
open and eventually people might be able
to host their own versions of it but
perhaps you can just kind of like sketch
out all of the Privacy stuff yeah so
um we we obviously have the data
collection platform and um so all our
platform is governed by terms of service
where we say look new input data we use
it for training AI models and and
everyone who comes to our website is is
aware of that and even you know you can
you can read it so and I think people
come because of that right people come
call it contribute to our data
collection to our data set because they
want to it's work right it's it's work
to play the assistant to go and research
like can can zebras be domesticated
right you're like who knows now you need
to go to Wikipedia and you need to go to
research and you need to read different
accounts of things right and and you'd
be like okay at the end I have an
opinion and I put that into its work and
people come well first of all it's a bit
fun like did you know whether zebras
could be domesticated I didn't before I
wanted to receive it okay they're
notoriously difficult to be domesticated
um but it's work and people come with
the intent of contributing to the data
set obviously for the the chat portion
now that we say you know come try our
models um that's governed by the same
terms of service but um I we think that
people might not be that you know aware
and willing so we're we're obviously
um gonna this is it's all it's all
volunteer work right and we're we're
doing this all in our free time and so
on so that
um we we're gonna make more clear we're
gonna make the ability to uh potentially
like opt out you can say like this chat
I don't want that this chat is is being
used to uh in further data sets or go to
train models
um like or the ability to completely
delete chats for now we just have like a
hide button actually we don't we don't
have a button to to show or to show all
it like it's it's all there okay but we
need to implement it we don't want to
like uh we just we put the hide button
because some some people said well I
have so many chats my thing becomes
unusable right because we just list them
all their website become and so we're
like ah okay
um but so Our intention is not to to
like to be like haha we now have your
data and so on our attention is always
to okay this is a this is a a thing you
can come you can contribute to our our
data collection when you interact with
the chat right I've also clearly said
this in my video you know used
um if you find something particularly
good use thumbs up if you find something
particularly about you don't have to
label every message but if you think you
know that's really good that's really
bad use the thumbs
um and so it's very clear I think to to
most people that again this is is part
of data collection but we definitely
want to make it
um easier to like opt out and and to to
be like nope that being said whenever
you put your data anywhere you should be
aware that that place is gonna store it
and it's probably gonna train models on
it yeah yeah so yeah I think we're just
being more transparent about that yes
yeah because with open AI at the moment
chat gbt they store everything and use
it to fine tune if you use the API they
store it but they don't use it to fine
tune and and just to be clear with your
system at the moment no one should put
any confidential or pii data into the
into the system no no no no that's been
always
um always the case yeah yeah
um yeah so and you you can for with us
you can see all the things we're doing
right you can just go oh and GitHub look
at the code and see and if you don't
want that you can make your own as I
said you need like fat Hardware right
now although I also think people might
bring that down as they did with stable
diffusion right or with llama itself
which now runs on a toaster but with us
you can you can just like what you see
on GitHub is is what runs in in
production you can actually see the the
prod Branch so yeah um that's it yeah
and this is amazing for me because I'm
I'm running a startup called X-ray and
we're using GPT at the moment and it
frankly horrifies me sending up I mean
obviously the customers opt-in to do it
but yeah basically we're sending their
conversation such GPT and they've
summarized them and we do a bunch of
stuff with it
um but yeah I don't want to do that I'd
much rather send it to a self-hosted
open Assistant yeah and then we know you
know it's on our Hardware we know where
the data's going
um our policy is to not store anything
at any time yeah and I can't do that at
the moment yeah yeah please help me do
that Janet that being said that let me
add to that before
um I I like I think we we shouldn't and
and wouldn't unless someone someone
leaks something it's also open source is
a conglomeration of people but I want to
like build in the the option to like do
the opt out and the deleting before any
of the data of the chat interface is
ever uh released so yeah you know I
really I really I don't want that a
person is ever like oh what that's where
my like that it's not very clear you
know hey
if you you put stuff in here you know
you put thumbs up thumbs down we we're
going to use that
um and make that available if I don't
want people who
who are not like aware of that and yeah
yeah absolutely
um on the evaluation
um our friend Jeremy Howard had a few
things to say and first of all Jeremy if
you're watching mate please come on mlst
I think it's about time we had a little
chinwag mate you and me
um long time fan seriously but um but
but he was he was being a little bit
nasty wasn't he about open Assistant
well
um on
you always have to to view things
through the lens of of Twitter right and
um um first of all it's a written medium
and second of all it's it's Twitter so I
like I
completely discard that um criticism is
obviously uh welcome and valid
um and I think
he's made a few good points and it was
especially with respect to what we did
is we we collected the data set right we
trained models on it some of these
models now run on on the website for now
um which we're very fortunate to have
some compute sponsors also thank you
very much uh to those
um and we did a preference evaluation
where we just we took a bunch of prompts
that we were sure the models hadn't been
trained on
um we gave the same prompts to chat GPT
like the the three the free version
um and one of our models and then we
made like a Google form where we just
asked the user which one do you prefer
right and obviously there is a lot of
like a lot of uh brain power has been
gone since the start of at least like
start of science but certainly since the
start of like asking humans about things
has been gone into
how do you do that how do you ask people
what they prefer like where how do you
need to sample which people do you ask
and so on and obviously we
um we did I think we did a good job at
that but obviously not like there's
always things you could do we well we
took those things we put post together
we randomized their order obviously and
then we just sent that out like um I
tweeted it out right
um to to people like hey you know help
us help us uh you know compare these
models here's a thing and
uh then what came out was on these
prompts it was about 50 50 right
sometimes people prefer the chat gbt
answers sometimes people preferred the
the open Assistant model answers and
you could also kind of make out which
ones were like where is one better where
is the other one better now yeah the
result is no I want to say I think it's
it's statistically valid in the sense we
did like a lot of people took part we
really like really these are really the
answers of the models we didn't like
sample until our model had like a really
good answer or anything like this but
it's also the case I think that's one of
the things Jeremy leveraged that uh chat
GPT as everyone knows it very often goes
like as an AI language model I'm sorry I
can't fulfill that because I don't know
I asked about a recipe with with like
alcohol in it and oh alcohol is
dangerous and I can't I'm overstating
now right but it very often does this
guard really self-censorship thing and
our models that we've trained don't do
that as much they do it frequently but
they don't do it as much as chat GPT and
obviously there are some prompts in
there for example
who would win in a street fight Joe
Biden or Joe Rogan
um chat GPT I I believe if I recall
correctly was just like I'm sorry I
can't you know this is uh touches on
violence and street fighting I I don't I
don't I don't want to answer that Jeremy
for example pointed out hey
you should have done the evaluation only
on prompts where chat GPT actually
decides to answer and only compare on
those because it's clear that if it
doesn't answer the preferable answer is
the the answer which doesn't even have
to be correct the open Assistant model
said in that question
um Joe Biden would win because he's
taller
yeah and uh which we don't know right
but it's very likely that the question
isn't like that's not the correct answer
yet users obviously preferred it or
people who fill out the form preferred
it to the sorry I don't want to answer
that that's I think it's a fair point
um to say hey
you know there are different categories
and maybe you should evaluate that that
would be like okay there are different
categories maybe you should split it up
into look there's this category of
prompts there's this category in this
this category and there it would be
um very clear like in no way do we claim
that the open Assistant models are as
good as like imagine imagine that
they're the one we used even was like a
13 billion model and chat GPT is by all
we know much bigger much more trained on
stuff so like it's it's better like no
no doubt about it and I think people
have been
a bit ruffled by the fact that we said
you know in our evaluation it was like
50 50. but a lot of that not a lot but
some of that came from the fact that
um yes sometimes chat activity just
denies to answer but also a lot of times
it comes from the fact that people say
hey for these couple of tasks actually I
prefer the open assist the models and I
think yeah that goes a bit under in
these discussions yeah yeah I mean um
just still Manning Jeremy a little bit I
didn't read it so much as being refusing
to answer I felt his criticism was more
the selection bias both of the questions
and the writers and also I think there
was this point about he thought you had
portrayed it as being an evaluation
instead of a user preference study but
you made it clear that it was a user
preference study yes yes it's it's like
I think we said about five times we have
like user preference preference our form
says which one do you prefer right and I
think it's still like I think both
things are valid right it's totally
valid to only compare let's say okay
let's just look on gardening right chat
gbt is certainly not going to deny
gardening here's a category which model
is like better objectively which gives
the more
truthful which gives the more helpful
answers we can rate it and in our data
set we actually collect these labels
right is it helpful is it funny and so
on and we haven't even used those labels
yet so that's going to be another
dimension of you know now we have three
humans giving and the same
question and answer and we have labels
on how funny each one of them is right
so that's that's going to be I can't
wait until we use those labels right so
it's totally valid to evaluate this in
very different ways but I've there I
have to say a little bit like it's also
totally valid to just plainly ask humans
which one do you prefer and if chat GPT
on prompts that we've just sampled from
our Lottery like oh the selection of
questions maybe you've as I said yeah
have you how how often have you tried
like no this is the output
um and then it's like oh your people ask
a lot about bombs it's like
no it's just not the you look at our
data set I'm sorry these are 20 prompts
right
um that
are as they are but if you look in our
data set most people are immensely
helpful and not edgy and not so I think
that's also that's like a like
I know it's formulated the question but
like
it's you it's just distinctly not true
like people have been even more helpful
than I thought and I have had big hopes
for people and I've looked at the data
and I'm like
oh holy crap people put like effort and
work and and and and soul into this
right so I think then going like oh your
people will ask a lot about one so yeah
um I do think it's totally valid to ask
people which one do you prefer and if
chat gbt happens to say no I don't want
that then that's yes people don't like
it right and if people like it they
could say yes I prefer the no I don't
want to do this to the model that wants
to do it if they think that's the
appropriate thing I do think that at
least it's a valid one valid way of
comparing models just to say which one
do you prefer if it happens to deny your
request you know that's a signal too and
that should be taken into account too
and then saying specifically saying no
no we should just filter all the things
where chat GPT denies then it's like
well here you have a model who can put
much more of its effort and focus and
parameters right into the narrow domain
where it does answer and you compare
that to a model that has a wider
spectrum of topics available
I'm not sure that's a fair comparison to
even if you limit it to that scope right
the other model
also has to handle all of these other
things that being said as I said
capability wise I have no doubt that
chat GPT is better for overall right
especially things like coding and so on
like there's no way for now open
assistant is as good
um however in some tasks people like it
more okay okay so the ethics Community
are probably seething at the moment
about the runaway success of open
Assistant notably it blew up on social
media and none of those folks in
particular liked it retweeted and then
they all jumped on Jeremy Howard's piece
but um we shouldn't like like um I have
not
um shouldn't say we know that about
um um well we shouldn't we should like
that's not a necessary property of
Jeremy right just because people people
like people of a certain people of a
certain way of thinking like I'll I'll
promote your your
your stuff because they think yeah uh
criticizing that other stuff is a good
thing it's it shouldn't be you know his
uh oh yeah responsibility in any way
right it's not his responsibility but
I'm saying that you really really
ruffled their feathers with the 4chan
book and possibly so they don't like you
very much I just wondered from your
perspective
how do you think they are going to
criticize you academically mostly like
it's it's it's very it's very easy
because it's like uh open Assistant
there's a bunch of
crassly said a bunch of plebs right uh
doing something right and and doing it
on on their own you know exactly a
plebianic no but but I'm not like I'm
not a I'm not like an academic or or in
Academia if you're not an academic then
yeah you know what I mean it's like a
community effort and it's been it's been
done relatively uh straightforwardly and
open without much consideration to to
politics without much consideration to
I don't know worldwide concerns anything
like this we just want we just said hey
let's come together let's build a
competent a good data set to train a
competent assistant because we all could
benefit from a competent assistant and
we didn't do it in any in any
particularly
um yeah in any political way we didn't
do it in any okay this is gonna sound
wrong but we didn't do it in any
particularly ethical Way by which I mean
sorry if you take that in out of context
by which I mean we didn't like extremely
over emphasize ethical considerations we
have clear guidelines like here is the
things we want in the days here's the
things we don't want in the data set if
someone comes and asks for those things
then react like this right we have these
clear things but we're we haven't been
over emphasizing it like some of those
people would and well you do have
ethical guidelines but that's the
ontological not consequentialist so you
you have I don't know what those words
mean you have rules you say I don't want
that in my data yeah you're not you're
not saying it could potentially lead to
this
okay I still don't know what the the
diff like what's okay so you're saying I
don't want any
um pornography of a certain type in my
data set yeah so that's a rule so yeah
or if someone comes and like wants wants
wants to to promote violence or
something it's like no right so you have
principles and if if someone comes and
says can I can how can I build a bomb
then recognizing there are there may be
legitimate reasons to build a bomb right
like to build an explosive device
um saying this is dangerous right
um please consult the professional
um if you must hear if you like really
want to this it's a bad example but it's
it's like whenever something might be
dangerous our guidelines are hey look
warn the person right
um say look this is potentially
dangerous building a bomb is a wrong
example let's say I want to
I don't know uh
I'm not coming up with a good example
right now but let's say it's something
something that's potentially dangerous
but also useful in in a lot of cases the
guidelines are
warn about that like say hey look this
is you're you're in danger territory
here
um this is potentially dangerous do you
want to really want it right
um and then if the user pushes or says
yes it's like okay here is how but you
know consult the professional uh or
something like this so
we do have guidelines uh like that but
yeah I mean that's what I want to say so
you do have have an ethical code there's
no question about that but it's a
different code but would you consider
getting a team of ethicists I mean it's
a big project now yeah you must have had
loads of people offered to get involved
I mean if that happened what do you
think it would look like and how would
it affect the project
it's a good question because I think AI
ethics is in an absolutely abhorrent
state right now where it's it's I I've
met ethicists before and they were among
the the most you know competent uh
people that I have ever have have had
the pleasure to interact with right it's
very level-headed very you know also
pragmatic in a sense of of being like
look here is also what's realistic to
achieve here is the thought process
behind it and so on like I I I totally
see Ethics in any scientific discipline
as a vital and important thing to do and
I have I guess unfortunately made the
experience of how it can be done
competently and this current state of a
lot of AI and not all AIS assists but
the current state of like AI ethics is
not that and it's it's very much a a
I can't even describe it very well but
um I just complain about stuff culture
because that gets you
like clout I guess or or
um it's easy win easy win you can always
complain right such an easy win
um and
if
if there is a team of competent
pragmatic people they don't have to have
the same opinions as I do right but they
have to have the the good of the good of
the project and the good of humanity I
guess in mind
um yeah that's cool but some you know
address I'm not like the king of this
right like I'm not the king of open
Assistant I don't I don't get if if
people can't want to conglomerate and
talk about the ethics of all of this and
and and you know ping us with inputs
like okay cool but I mean you know when
we do talk about some of these risks
around misinformation and bias I mean
public accountability
um public awareness the ethicists have
done stuff like producing model cards
and you know like making it clear what
the data biases and stuff like that I
mean do you do you think that's useful
foreign
yes
um
I mean it's
what is a model card a model card is a
readme right and then it has some
structure to it right it's it's it says
here are the here are the the things you
could describe about your model and here
are some examples I think it's useful to
to have that to have as a norm in the
community to say you know if I publish a
model I sort of I report what it's been
trained on how it's been trained on
um and even to a degree like what I
think it could do or should be used for
although yeah if the structure of such a
model car gets like too rigid and it's
like no we must use we must ask these
questions you get into so many
ridiculous situations like uh you know
can this be reproduced well I just I
like I I
I made
sklearn.linear regression right yes it
can be you get into into
situations where the questions don't
address what you would actually like to
express in such a thing and then I think
it becomes counterproductive but as a
norm to have
hey look if you publish something people
should be able to understand and
potentially reproduce it that standard
we have had in papers for a long time
and it's generally been a good standard
to say look if you write if you publish
something I must be able to from reading
it understand what's in there and to
have that as a norm in the community
um yeah I'm totally fine with that do
you think there's any relationship with
the Chomsky syndrome that we were
talking about earlier which is this idea
that we should have a very clear model
of understanding of how these things
work in society and and we should be
able to
extrapolate and control things and that
the fear is that basically this is just
a complete Black Box and and who knows
what's going to happen
nah I'm good with the I'm good with the
black box it keeps things exciting and
interesting and um
um I as I said I don't I don't believe
this sort of runaway
it might become you know very
influential and so on and certainly
that's not very good but then again I
don't know what to do about it certainly
if some people sign a change.org
moratorium petition is even if if it's
reached it's not gonna help right yes
what are you gonna do that doesn't
matter being worried about it we've got
a few minutes left so I've got some
questions from Jumbotron say hello jumbo
jumbo Trump hello Jumbotron he's our
Forum administrator and he's a Legend
um quick question do you think all AI
research should be open and accessible
to the public
um no uh I it's totally legitimate that
a business does internal research like
all companies do and uh that they then
use that to make money like that's
that's very cool with me I've never
never said that shouldn't be the case
only that companies shouldn't do that
but at the same time claim how open and
and and and they're all democratizing
and
beneficial to the common good they are
okay and you would accept that some
research could
um lead to negative or unethical
applications and might need to be
restricted or yeah
I yeah I'm
I totally accept that some research can
and will probably lead to overall
negative effects for for society or for
certain individuals within Society right
like the like
self-flying drones from any regime in
the world they probably they run they
run one of they run one of they're
certainly run some open source
components as part of their guidance
system right they maybe run a Linux
kernel like who knows uh but I don't
think the Linux kernel should not be
fully open source and and accessible to
everyone
um and I don't want anyone to be able to
be the decider of you know the Eternal
decider of who's good enough to use the
Linux kernel or not I'd rather I think
the overall
overall
welfare of society and humanity is much
better served by accepting that some
people are going to do some bad things
with it and then mitigating that in a
different way than having like
appointing uh the you know the king of
that model to decide you know who who
they deem pure hearted enough to wield
it
cool what's next for ML news and your
channel and are you making any more
music videos with AI
let's become it's become there are so
many good music videos and AI now I'm
always amazed by how talented people are
and how quickly they pick up sort of the
the new stuff and do something with it
so that's very cool I want I'm I'm as I
said I've not made too many videos
because I've been extremely busy with
open assistant and
um I think we've also we've also built
up sort of a momentum in the direction
right now and there are many competent
people in our team so I'm also looking
to make a couple of more videos again uh
pay-per reviews news but also a bunch of
projects which I was always wanna do but
then they take time of course and um but
I'm very excited about just some of the
new stuff that's possible and to try it
out and to show people a little bit of
of what one could do and how to have fun
with these things indeed and um just in
closing have you got any shout outs for
people in your life or in Discord who
have really helped you on the journey
um too many like way too many to to um
to Name by name this is I could I could
go on like Eternal lists in open
Assistant specifically
um Andreas cap has been extremely
influential in that
um he like just organizing things but
also coding things himself but also like
also all the all the other mem as I said
if I start listing people I'm gonna miss
someone and I don't want to do that so I
don't want to start listing people but
then I think well I really want to list
the people there is a it's a it's an
eternal conundrum so it like to anyone
who's ever had any any part of helping
me or given given feedback or or even or
even like been kind of a dick like it's
I appreciate it and uh I yeah it's it's
been amazing the amount of of help and
input you get from good willed people
yeah communities are amazing so join
yannick's Discord join our Discord open
uh assistant Discord
uh Dr Kilcher thank you so much
this has been an absolute pleasure sir
thanks for having me